[Music]
so you see this madness are you ready
for the madness that will be a wrinkle
in time in about a month I can't even
like think about it like it kind of
makes me like dumbfounded like I can't
even fathom the excitement I have and
it's so close so I'm really excited and
I can't wait do you know how much this
means to like women like me of my
generation who grew up with this book it
was one of my favorites when I was a
girl and I dreamed that the heroine
looked like you even though I always
thought it was imagined to look like
someone else
yes yes it's absolutely incredible and I
feel like it's such a blessing because
right now in this robe we do need
diversity and we do need representation
and inclusion so to be able to inspire
women and young little african-american
girls to say that you could live out
your dreams and you can be on TV if you
want to be on TV or you can be the
superhero that you are it's just like so
mean how old are you okay so you know as
Miss win for his birthday today I know
I can't believe because it's been a year
and we celebrated her birthday on set so
it's just like so amazing and I can't
believe we've come this far and I just
want to wish her a happy birthday and I
love her dearly and she's an amazing
person I'm gonna do an Instagram post of
our photos we're trying to get a collage
together now yes but I just love her to
death
storm also opened up about the
possibility of her a wrinkle in time
character Meg becoming a far be doll
after it was announced the Mrs W ladies
of the movie will be I would cry I would
be so emotional because I of course I
love playing with Bratz dolls and
Barbies and American Girl dolls but
there was hue that kind of looked like
me and that had curly hair and that are
nerdy and like geeky so it would just
mean the world so hopefully it comes
around
[Music]